[MUSIC PLAYING]
The thing about the
clarinet is that it
can have worlds of expression.
And it can do that in so many
different styles of music,
from classical music
to jazz, to rock,
to all kinds of world music.
And I felt that this
project was a way
to remind everybody the
possibilities of it.
We're going to
hear in one evening
the clarinet played by
many different people
in many different ways.
We're hearing it
in a jazz setting,
we're hearing it in
an orchestral setting.
And I think that gave a nice
opportunity for the audience
to experience the full
breadth of this instrument.
I was glad to be invited.
And there's some other good
clarinet players playing,
so I'm happy to be here.
The clarinet is a phenomenally
expressive instrument,
even though its tone tends
to be on the darker side.
Any instrument that has
survived for centuries
is there because people
have consistently
found it to be a good
conduit for the channeling
of human thoughts and
feelings and ideas
and emotions into sound.
My journey with the clarinet--
this little fella has been
with me for over 30 years now.
I started to play jazz when
I got into high school.
And I thought, I'm going to
be able to play clarinet.
But clarinet went out
of fashion, apparently.
I did not know.
So the teacher was--
he kind of discouraged me
from playing the clarinet.
He said why don't you bring
your brother's saxophone
or any saxophone?
Just don't bring the clarinet.
When I was real little,
my dad was a jazz fan.
He'd always have-- he
listened to these saxophone
recordings of David Sanborn.
Third grade is where you
would-- the earliest age you
could join the band program.
And so every year they
would show the beginning
third graders and
have a presentation,
where the fourth and fifth
graders they would go and play
their instruments on stage
and the third graders
in the audience.
And then it was to try to
convince them to join the band
and to pick an instrument.
And so I kind of wanted
to play saxophone
because a little bit
of my dad's influence.
That was his
favorite instrument.
But the clarinet
was a lot smaller
and then I realized that
it could fit in my backpack
and I wouldn't have to lug
around the heavier saxophone.
So back in the
origin of jazz, back
in Dixieland and New
Orleans type jazz,
the clarinet was a very
prominent instrument.
When jazz changed a lot from
the swing era to the bebop era,
there were no famous
bebopist clarinetists.
You had Charlie Parker
on the saxophone.
And that's part
of the reason why
the saxophone has
become probably
the dominant instrument in jazz.
Clarinetists are
mostly in big bands
playing this older swing stuff.
And so they didn't quite make
the shift over to the new era
immediately.
There have been bebopist
this clarinetists since then,
but there were no real figures
for people to look up to,
I guess.
One, two, three, one.
[SOUNDING MUSICAL NOTES]
You need to articulate.
It's all going somewhere.
Go.
[SOUNDING MUSICAL NOTES]
OK.
Well, it was another
one of Fred's ideas.
This whole thing came
to me in a dream.
And I can't believe
it actually happened.
It hasn't happened yet,
but we've gotten this far.
So this is very, very cool.
Last year he mentioned something
about a clarinet summit
where you would get Evan Ziporyn
and my instructor Billy Novick
and potentially some
other people to come play.
Don Byron.
Right here.
Eran Egozy.
Billy Novak.
Evan Ziporyn.
Fred's idea was to have a
piece at the end of the concert
that would involve
all five players
and that would be in some way
tailored to their strengths
and their inclinations,
their musical inclinations.
And asked me if I could
write such a piece.
If we're celebrating
the clarinet,
then why don't we
really go all the way
and celebrate it by
inviting people who play it?
I saw this concert advertised.
Then I saw, if you bring
your own instrument,
you can play along.
And three--
The fact that we're
inviting clarinetists
from around town to
come and actually
play with us, that's
kind of unprecedented.
If you just invite the
community at large,
then you're opening yourself
up to all levels of performance
ability and intonation and time.
94.
When to have these
16th note figures.
Those should not be articulate.
It's really like,
[SOUNDING MUSICAL NOTES]
That kind of thing.
I mean, you tongue it, but the
airstream should not be broken.
Really, up until the
performance it kind of
had that edge of
your seat quality.
Like, is this even
going to work?
Is it going to fall apart?
I've been learning new notes
throughout the rehearsals.
It's complicated.
It's complicated music.
A lot of shifting time
signatures and things.
And I'm not used to that.
I really love the
fact that this concert
is going to be, not just
about celebrating the clarinet
but celebrating community.
To be able to play with these
great clarinetists, that's
just, you know,
once in a lifetime.
The rhythm to this
piece changes so often
that it's really fun to play.
The whole thing about the
clarinet is that it-- to me,
is a singularly kind of 18th,
19th century contraption.
If you look at it it's
basically a recorder
with a bunch of doo
hickeys attached to it.
What I'm trying to do is
use all these contraptions
and use the acoustic nature
of the instrument-- it's just
this wooden tube that
has a lot of overtones
and harmonics hidden
in it, and just kind of
bring those things out.
What's idiomatic
on the instrument
are things like Mozart, like--
But for me I'm much more
interested in finding ways
to get in the cracks.
And so instead of
playing like scales,
I much prefer to
do things like--
that's based on an
African Ya Titi.
Or do things that try
to make the instrument
sound like a Shakuhachi flute.
It's a wonderful program
and a great opportunity
and a wonderful
gesture that Fred
is bestowing upon
us, the clarinetists,
to shine a spotlight on
this great instrument.
The clarinet's such
a nerdy instrument.
Let's face it.
The clarinet's more difficult
to play than the saxophone.
So it's harder to play like
fancier stuff and complex
changes.
And also the clarinet isn't
as loud as the saxophone
or the trumpet or
other instruments.
So it's like an
adult instrument.
As far as the tone quality and
things you can do, they're--
may be much more
nuanced than sax.
But it also has a
tremendous range.
It has a range of
over three octaves.
It sounds different
in every range,
so you can have a variety of
sounds that can come from it.
I did not realize how
versatile of an instrument
the clarinet was when
I first chose it.
You have what's known as
the chalumeau register,
the low register.
Very warm.
Very rich.
Then you have like really
high, bright stuff like--
This is called the clarion
register, and clarion kind
of like a bell.
And then the altissimo register,
which is the next register.
A very kind of more powerful,
kind of penetrating, piercing,
annoying, people
might say sometimes.
I like using different
registers to sort of capture
different voices, almost
accompanying myself.
I started playing the
instrument because I had asthma
and my doctor said,
either I could swim
or I could play a
wind instrument.
And everybody knows
black people can't swim.
So I ended up playing
a clarinet then.
I got a good sound on it.
It wasn't intended to be
a career move of any kind,
but then it kind of
ended up being that.
When I play the
clarinet I really
feel that I can be myself.
It's a great instrument.
And it really can be part
of so many different sounds.
The wonderment of the
world is, of course,
based on Middle Eastern and
Islamic and Spanish medieval
themes.
So I had a sense that she
would have a connection to it
that nobody else would,
being from Israel.
It really goes straight
into your heart.
I'm working hard for people
to realize that it's not just
belong to the music of
New Orleans or not just
Benny Goodman.
Clarinetists like
Anat and I have
explored a lot of
ethnic things that
are neither jazz or classical
because in those musics
there's more clarinet, there's
more clarinet in Trinidadian
music, in Colombian
music, in Brazilian music,
in all of the Eastern
European countries.
There's even maybe
more Asian clarinet
than there is jazz clarinet.
They're incredible players.
If you look up modern jazz
clarinetists on Google,
Don Byron and Anat Cohen pop up.
The chance to play
along with people
whose music I've listened to
over a decade seems unreal.
[MUSIC PLAYING]